In diesem Video erfährst du, wie du deine
Tomaten ausgeizt, bei welchen Pflanzen man
das machen sollte, bei welchen man es sein
lassen sollte, warum das bei einigen Pflanzen
so wichtig ist, wie das Ganze funktioniert
und wann man das macht.
Also alles rund um das Thema Tomaten ausgeizen.
Da zeige ich dir den besten Weg, wie du das
machen kannst, so dass deine Pflanzen möglichst
gesund bleiben, dass sie einen großen Ertrag
abwerfen und dass die Früchte auch möglichst
aromatisch schmecken.
Ich habe dieses Jahr noch ganz viele andere
Tomaten-Videos geplant, die euch wirklich
durch das ganze Jahr führen sollen, so dass
ihr immer wisst, was wann bei euren Tomaten
antsteht.
Also drückt gerne den Abo-Button und auch
die Glocke, damit ihr informiert werdet, sobald
die nächsten Videos erscheinen.
Damit ich euch am besten weiterhelfen kann,
eure beste Tomatenernte überhaupt einzufahren
dieses Jahr.
Also kommt mit, los geht’s.
Wir sind jetzt zwar im Gewächshaus, aber
du musst natürlich auch Freilandtomaten oder
Tomaten, die du auf dem Balkon anbaust, ausgeizen,
außer es sind Buschtomaten oder Zwergtomaten.
Buschtomaten muss man nicht ausgeizen, die
kommen damit klar, dass sie ganz viele unterschiedliche
Triebe haben.
Das liegt daran, dass Buschtomaten und Zwergtomaten
eine bestimmte Anzahl von Früchten genetisch
produzieren können und wenn du die ausgeizt,
dann nimmst du eben quasi die Hälfte der
möglichen Früchte weg, die fallen dann einfach
weg.
Bei den anderen Tomaten ist das nicht so.
Da ist es dann nicht so, dass wenn man einen
Geiztrieb herausnimmt, dass dann die Pflanze
insgesamt weniger Tomaten produziert.
Im Gegenteil, die bleibt gesünder, die konzentriert
ihre ganze Kraft in die Triebe, die Fruchtansätze,
die man eben stehen lässt und ist viel luftiger.
Das ist auch wichtig, weil Tomaten ja sehr
anfällig sind für die Krautfäule.
Da muss man immer darauf achten, dass dazwischen
Luft zirkulieren kann.
Und deswegen gibt es total Sinn, Tomaten auszugeizen,
außer es sind eben Buschtomaten oder Zwergtomaten.
Bei denen würde das keinen Sinn ergeben,
weil man sich damit die Ernte einkürzt sozusagen.
Aber die anderen Tomaten, also alle, fast
alle Tomatensorten muss man eintriebig erziehen.
Man kann die auch zweitriebig erziehen, gerade
im Gewächshaus ergibt das Sinn.
Das macht man aber normalerweise eher mit
veredelten Tomaten.
Das kann man natürlich auch zu Hause ausprobieren.
Aber das ist eher etwas für den professionellen
Tomatenanbau.
Zu Hause würde ich schon jedem empfehlen,
die Tomaten eintriebig zu erziehen.
Wir werden uns jetzt einfach einmal eine Tomatenpflanze
anschauen, damit ihr vielleicht besser versteht,
was es mit diesen Trieben auf sich hat und
wie man denn die Geiztriebe findet, die man
entfernen soll.
Also hier ist unsere Tomatenpflanze und die
hat hier einen Stamm und davon gehen Blätter
ab.
Und zwischen diesen Blättern und dem Stamm
entstehen immer wieder kleine Triebe.
Die sind am Anfang natürlich noch winzig.
Es ist am besten, wenn man die so früh wie
möglich herausbricht, damit die Pflanze da
gar nicht erst ihre Energie hereinlenkt.
Manchmal werden die aber auch richtig groß.
Und dann bekomme ich immer Nachrichten von
Leuten, die sagen, ich kann doch jetzt nicht
diesen Geiztrieb entfernen, der blüht ja
schon.
Also da können sich doch schon jetzt Tomaten
daran bilden.
Und ich würde euch trotzdem immer empfehlen,
die abzumachen, die Geiztriebe.
Ja ich weiß, es tut manchmal weh, aber es
ist für die Pflanzen letztendlich besser,
wenn man auch große Geiztriebe wie der, den
ich euch jetzt einmal hier einblende, entfernt,
damit die eben eintriebig weiterwachsen und
man wirklich die ganze Power in den Früchten
hat, die sich an diesem einen Trieb bilden,
damit die Pflanzen gesünder bleiben.
Es ist so ärgerlich diese Krautfäule, die
kann einem so einen Strich durch die Rechnung
machen, gerade im Freiland bei Freilandtomaten.
Und es ist ganz wichtig, dass man das regelmäßig
macht und zwar am besten, bevor die Geiztriebe
so groß werden.
Übrigens kann man diese großen Geiztriebe,
wenn man denn einmal einen großen ausbrechen
muss, einfach in ein Glas Wasser stellen und
dann wurzeln die an und dann kann man wieder
eine neue Tomatenpflanze aus diesem Geiztrieb
ziehen.
Natürlich ist es ein bisschen spät, dann
jetzt noch Tomaten aus Geiztrieben zu ziehen.
Die werden nicht mehr so viel Ertrag abwerfen
wie die, die jetzt schon so riesig groß sind.
Aber die werden schon noch Früchte tragen
dieses Jahr, gerade gegen Ende der Saison,
wenn vielleicht die anderen Tomaten dann schon
ein bisschen schwächeln.
Also macht das gerne, wenn ihr noch ein paar
mehr Tomaten in eurem Garten haben wollt und
zieht einfach aus den Geiztrieben neue Tomatenpflanzen,
dann tut es auch gleich gar nicht mehr so
arg weh.
Ich weiß, es ist oft so, dass man auch einmal
einen Geiztrieb übersieht, und der wird dann
auf einmal riesengroß und dann ist man ganz
überrascht und vielleicht ein bisschen überfordert,
was man jetzt machen soll.
Deswegen, um das zu verhindern, um wirklich
möglichst alle Geiztriebe zu erwischen, wenn
sie noch ganz klein sind, habe ich einen Trick
für euch.
Und zwar geht ihr einfach einmal von oben
nach unten die Pflanze durch.
Also ihr schaut am Stengel herunter in jedes
Blattachsen-Paar, ob sich da ein Geiztrieb
gebildet hat und dann geht ihr da einmal jede
Blattachse durch.
Und so kann euch kein Geiztrieb mehr durch
die Latten gehen, hoffentlich.
Manchmal passiert das trotzdem noch.
Ich habe ja auch so einen Uschi und den dann
einfach herausbrechen, auch wenn es weh tut.
Und ein kleiner Tipp noch: Ich würde Tomaten,
wenn sie nass sind, also gerade wenn ihr vielleicht
Freilandtomaten anbaut, nicht anfassen.
Das haben wir auch auf dem Hof, wo ich früher
gearbeitet habe, immer so gemacht.
Wenn die Tomaten nass sind, dann lassen wir
die in Ruhe.
Weil, wenn wir dann Blätter ausbrechen, dann
können viel besser Krankheiten in die Pflanze
eindringen.
Man kann die Krankheiten von einer zur anderen
Pflanze übertragen.
Deswegen besser warten, bis die Pflanzen abgetrocknet
sind, bevor ihr irgendwelche Pflegearbeiten
an den Tomaten dann durchführt.
Ja genau, und wenn man das dann macht, dann
hat man eben diesen einen Haupttrieb, den
man an der Ranke oder am Seil hochführt und
der dann hoffentlich ganz viele tolle, leckere
Tomaten produziert, die dann auch aromatischer
sind.
Zumindest sagt man das den Tomaten nach, dass
wenn man sie ausgeizt, dass die mehr die ganze
Süße, den ganzen Geschmack in die Früchte
stecken, die sie dann eben produzieren.
Die werden besser reif, gerade gegen Ende
der Saison, wenn vielleicht noch viele grüne
Tomaten an deinen Pflanzen hängen.
Die kann man natürlich nachreifen.
Das Video kann ich euch einmal da oben verlinken,
aber dann ist es eben gut, wenn die Pflanze
die Kraft noch in die Früchte hereinstecken
kann, die eben noch daran hängen, so dass
die dann auch möglichst reifen werden.
Und dann habe ich noch einen kleinen Trick
für euch.
Wenn ihr einmal beim Ausgeizen oder beim Pflegen
eurer Tomaten die Spitze abbricht, also der
Haupttrieb ist ja diese Spitze hier oben,
die bis zum unteren Ende durchgeht.
Und manchmal passiert es, dass man aus Versehen
den Haupttrieb abbricht.
Und dann könnt ihr einen der oberen Geiztriebe
nehmen, stehen lassen und an eurer Ranke empor
leiten, so dass das der neue Haupttrieb wird.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich eine Tomate habe.
Ich glaube, ich habe da hinten eine Tomate
gesichtet, bei der das der Fall ist.
Falls ja, ich muss mir das gleich noch einmal
genau anschauen, kann ich euch das hier einblenden,
wie das dann aussieht.
Natürlich wirft das die Pflanze ein bisschen
in ihrer Entwicklung zurück.
Und man sollte möglichst aufpassen, dass
man ihr nicht weh tut, Aber wenn das einmal
passiert, dann ist das eben kein Problem,
einfach einen der oberen Haupttriebe stehen
zu lassen und den als neuen Haupttrieb nach
oben zu leiten.
Ah, voilà.
Hier ist uns vor ein paar Wochen einmal der
Haupttrieb abgebrochen, an dieser Stelle hier.
Und dann habe ich einfach diesen Geiztrieb
stehen gelassen und leite den jetzt einfach
an der Schnur nach oben, so dass der sich
zum neuen Haupttrieb entwickelt hat und die
Pflanze trotzdem noch weiter nach wachsen
kann.
Da seht ihr noch einmal die Wunde.
Es ist alles gut verheilt.
Und jetzt haben wir eben trotzdem unsere Tomatenpflanze,
man sieht ja das auch von weitem gar nicht
so arg an.
Ich verlege euch einmal da drüben ein Video,
um Tomaten zu düngen.
Ist ja jetzt auch super wichtig, dass man
weiß, wie man seine Tomaten düngt.
Da unten ist auch noch ein spannendes Video.
Und wie gesagt, wenn ihr Lust habt auf noch
mehr Tomaten-Tipps, wenn euch dieses Video
gefallen hat, dann abonniert den Kanal und
drückt die Glocke, damit ihr Bescheid bekommt,
sobald das nächste Tomaten-Video erscheint.
Bis dann, tschüss!